[Music]
how you doing FR not bad I'd love to
introduce you all to the newest member
of our little family this is Roberts
hello hey friend right
he
friend sorry I scared you I'm sneaking
up on people boaga
[Music]
Booga remember we call us ha coffee no
depresso you're funny have plans
tonight so did you like the movie I
didn't really like anything about that
movie what do you like my job what about
it
I'm good at
it tell me something about you got
divorced I guess I can't seem to figure
it out figure one out
love secretly good at a lot of things
you just don't let anyone
know found me on the road to
Gena
I like you I want to get to know you but
you just won't let me and I don't know
what to do it's confusing what do you
want from me why is it so hard with
you do you wish you could unknow
me it's hard isn't
it being a
[Music]
person was
good